[Music]
I'm Alan aim I work on google kubernetes
engine at Google part of our product
management organization and I'm joined
here by Rohit our guru wallah hi
everyone it's a privilege to be speaking
here at next and talking to everybody
here like Alan mentioned I'm a principal
engineer at Cisco and the overall
architect for the Cisco and Google
solution and as Alan goes through the
first part of the section I'll go into
more details and as well give you a nice
overview of the demo as part of the
solution yeah so let's talk about what
we're gonna cover in this session so by
the end of the session we'd like you to
walk away with really an understanding
around you know what are the use cases
that the Google Cisco hybrid cloud
offering actually unlocks and then what
are the components that make up this
particular all these various use cases
so we're gonna really focus on you know
working through the stack and all the
various components that make up the
stack talk about the different use cases
and then Rohit is actually going to show
you a super cool demo it's actually very
exciting demo that leverages all these
various technologies together and shows
you the power of it so before I get
started the show of hands how many
developers here in this audience
okay how about IT admins business folks
cool
anyone here running containers and
production
okay what about kubernetes and
production nice anybody running google
kubernetes engine right on great so
let's get started you know when you look
at the overall cloud evolution you know
we've gone through these phases every 10
years and you know we are currently
somewhere between the the red and blue
dot in terms of evolution taking place
today that's real
been driven by transformation that
containers have really brought to the
market for a long time the only path
forward was really from an
infrastructure as a service perspective
a lift and shift to the cloud and then
modernize in the cloud and we've really
been looking at ways in terms of
bringing all the various goodness of the
cloud to you wherever you're running
your application so that you can
modernize where you are and move to the
cloud at your own pace so this trend
that we're seeing right now around cloud
native services is really something that
the market is picking up on and I have
to say in my entire career in the IT
industry I haven't seen this much
traction as I'm seeing right now this
whole notion of being able to build
services that can literally run anywhere
and being able to manage them from a
central location I think is key to this
trend that we're seeing right now around
cloud native services and then hybrid
has really become an enterprise reality
I'm sure a lot of you have applications
that probably fall into any one of these
categories here for very long time the
only path was really to go from on-prem
to public cloud and that's a great path
but as Diane alluded to in the keynote
only 10 percent of applications today
have really migrated to the public cloud
there's a reason for that running and
migrating applications from on-prem to
the public cloud is hard right many
organizations are looking at figuring
out how to take a monolith break it up
into micro services figure out where to
run these micro services you run them on
Prem do you run them in the cloud how do
you connect these services together you
know some of you probably have
portfolios of thousands of applications
each applications has different
characteristics and data privacy
requirements some have to stay on Prem
some can easily move to the cloud how do
you figure all that out but the key here
is how do you manage that portfolio of
application in such a way where you're
doing it consistently right without
having to use this tool for on Prem this
school for cloud this tool for
micro-services a different tool for
policy management and different tool for
security that those are really hard
problems our goal here really is to
bridge these two worlds together right
so on one hand you have the
modernization evolution that's happening
from an on-prem standpoint you have
administrators and architects looking at
taking workloads that can't easily move
to the cloud and modernizing them and
it's in the path that we're seeing here
with a lot of customers is they're
taking tools like kubernetes and
figuring out how to run them in on-prem
environments so that they can take
existing applications and containerize
them and modernize in place so that they
can eventually move to the public cloud
at a pace that they're comfortable with
at the same time there's this very fast
move that's happening where developers
are going off and container izing their
applications and running running them in
the cloud so as an organization you have
to be able to manage all these various
requirements that are coming from your
developers from your IT admins from your
architects how do you do that and what
we're going to talk about today is
really bridging together all these
various components right where a
developer can't go from source to image
to container to deployment environment
and then a admin can come along and
specify policy associated with how these
applications run together who can talk
to what who has access to various
components within the architecture so
all these various roles would work
together in terms of providing that
end-to-end state where you're getting
application agility you're getting
faster time-to-market
and at the same time IT has control over
the environment and and you're
abstracting away the underlying
complexity is the infrastructure as much
as possible this is our goal so what if
what if you can just focus on innovating
focus on writing code
then have the platform solve all the
gnarly problems associated with
connectivity associated with policy
enforcement and make it in such a way
that it's all API driven and you get the
best of both worlds what if you can do
that so at Google our open hybrid cloud
strategy's really been focused on three
core tenants the first is kubernetes
kubernetes has been growing like crazy
since its introduction into the open
source world than for years now
kubernetes has seen dramatic growth and
is now the de-facto Orchestrator for
containers on the market and what
kubernetes allows you to do is build
services and run services and and deploy
services very quickly in a continuous
fashion right it makes it more
predictable to make changes to
applications and it gives you the
ability now to run these services and
environments that are heterogeneous in
nature whether it's on one cloud on
different clouds on-premise without
having to rewrite your code right that's
the beauty of kubernetes then there's
another component called open service
broker open service broker is really a
standard around consuming cloud services
where you can consume these services
pretty much from anywhere and this is
also an open source project and then
finally sto and I'm sure a lot of you
been hearing this week a lot of
information about us few SEO is another
open source project that was developed
in conjunction between Google lyft and
IBM where it solves the challenges
associated with managing all these
various services that you've created in
heterogeneous environments how do you
connect these services together how do
you enforce ensure that connectivity is
secure and get observability around what
these services are doing so if you're in
the keynote you probably saw a really
cool demo around how SEO can get metrics
and then stackdriver expose all
dependency graphs in terms of how your
services are communicating together and
roll heads going to go really deep into
SEO in our talk and give you really a
high level around what it is how it
works and our demo will actually be
using Sto so the Cisco hybrid platform
for Google Cloud is really about one
very important key tenet is the ability
to write once deploy anywhere right it's
about being able to build your
application take your containers run
them on kubernetes and be able to run
those containers whether it's on Google
Chrome brew Nettie's engine or
on-premise on Cisco container platform
the whole idea is it's really about
agility and control right
you shouldn't have to rewrite your
application when you move it from
environment environment and this is a
goal that we're targeting together in
terms of building this offering so why
are we doing this the key here is hybrid
has really become an overused term right
a lot of times when people think about
hybrid they think about you know an a
single application that spans multiple
environments as a matter of fact that's
a small portion of the hybrid use cases
that exist out there today many cases
hybrid is about managing different
applications in different environments
in a consistent fashion right so as
people adopt a hybrid strategy they run
into big challenges right first is
connectivity how do you connect from
on-premise to the public cloud right in
a secure fashion in a fashion where you
have control around it and you can
enforce policy around who has access to
what how do you spin up these kubernetes
environments anywhere right and do it in
such a way that's consistent with the
experience that you have running in the
cloud how do you manage these kubernetes
environments again consistently where
you're writing your application once and
deploying them anywhere and then support
who's going to support this right you
want a single support arm that will
support your entire hybrid deployment
right that's the key and this is what
Cisco brings to the table
our joint hybrid offering these are very
hard problems to solve and Google and
Cisco partner together to bring really
the best of both worlds in terms of what
both companies bring to the table from a
Google standpoint we bring kubernetes we
bring a lot of the innovations that we
put forward from an open-source
standpoint around kubernetes and SEO and
and the work that we've done around
google kubernetes engine we also bring a
set of services that we've developed
around application connectivity and all
these various components so together
we're bringing the best of what both
companies do and offering it in such a
way where it's turnkey and consumable
and supported consistently across your
hybrid environment and that's our goal
so some of the use cases that we're
enabling and we'll be talking you know
in greater detail especially around the
third use case but the first use case is
how do I connect from public cloud to a
system that's sitting on premise that
can't move to the public cloud right
think of a legacy system or some non
rest-based interface that isn't
modernized how do I do that this is the
first use case that we've enabled the
second is really about how do I consume
cloud services from on-prem from
kubernetes in such a way that's
consistent across my environment maybe
I'd like to consume from Google cloud
maybe I want to consume from other
clouds but I want to consume my these
services using a consistent interface
and then the third use case is really
around hybrid CI CD continuous
integration development where I'd like
to be able to write my application
perhaps for the public cloud but then
move it around different environments
without having to rewrite my application
maybe I wanted you canary in public
cloud and then trickle requests and then
eventually push it into production or
Bluegreen tests and things that nature
blue green deployments that's really
about the third use case of CI CD
deployments so for the first use case
the idea here is we want to enable our
customers to be able to innovate and
build applications in the public cloud
but then these applications should
easily be able to connect with systems
that are sitting in your data centers
and we do that by leveraging google
apogee and google apogee is an api
gateway that really takes interfaces
that are non modern non rest interfaces
and it's a layer that sits in front of
it and makes these interfaces consumable
by modern applications so think of a use
case where you've got a system that
storing custom customer data that can't
move into the public cloud maybe you're
in a regulated industry where the data
can't move country boundaries or things
of that nature and then you want to
build a mobile app that needs to really
scale for performance standpoint and you
build that mobile app in the public
cloud now that mobile app can handle all
the various requests that are coming in
from a front-end standpoint and scale
efficiently but then can communicate
with these legacy systems that are
sitting in your data center via the
apogee gateway that's the first use case
and the key here is the work that we're
doing with cisco is really about pulling
together they're called like approved
reference architectures that give you
these capabilities in a deployment model
so that you're not having to install all
the various components separately right
you want connectivity there's a Cisco
CVD that basically addresses this use
case and gives you this particular
architectural pattern the second use
case is about consuming Google cloud
services so we in Google cloud we have
the service called open service broker
and what open service broker does is it
gives you the ability to consume Google
cloud services from outside of Google
cloud in a consistent fashion so that
you don't have to worry about the
semantics associated with things like
service accounts you know having to
figure out you know how to translate
information
from on-prem to the public cloud service
open service broker basically leverages
a component within kubernetes called
service catalog which initiates a
session with open service broker and
then passes tokens that gives you the
ability now to communicate with that
cloud service and consume it from
outside of Google Cloud so it abstracts
away the complexities around security
around the various semantics associated
with that consumption pattern and in the
third use case is really about a hybrid
CI CD pattern right so the idea here is
supposed to have an application
containerized application running in
production i've got a new version coming
out i can deploy that new version in
google cloud run some canary testing and
then be able to once things are I'm
positive from a policy standpoint that
things are working properly I can now
have that trickle into production and
have a new version that's running and no
impact on my user experience and this is
what Rohit is actually going to do a
demo later on in our session and show
you how that all works and before I hand
it over to Rohit to talk about the Cisco
components let me just spend a bit of
time talking about google kubernetes
engine so I'm sure some of you have been
in sessions talking and and watched sort
of the kubernetes engine pitch and so
forth but I want to highlight just a few
things so google kubernetes engine has
been a ga product now for three years
it is a managed kubernetes service that
runs on Google cloud platform
it is 100% upstream kubernetes this is
not a two versions behind whenever
there's a new version of kubernetes
which is every three months google
kubernetes engine supports that new
version within a couple of weeks within
a kubernetes cluster there's usually a
master and there is worker nodes with
kubernetes engine Google manages the
master we give you the ability to auto
upgrade anytime there's a new
version will notify you we will also
Auto upgrade your nodes again through
notification it's really up to you to
tell us how you want those upgrades to
take place we have an SRE team sitting
at Google that manages the health of
that cluster anything happens we fix it
we ensure your applications are running
are healthy it is integrated with the
underlying Google cloud autoscaler so
you're not only getting container auto
scaling but you're getting underlying
node auto scaling so you can define
thresholds and integrate with stack
driver for logging and monitoring it's
built on top of Google's Network so it's
a global network you can have clusters
running in different regions that can
talk to each other and from a compliance
standpoint it is certified across all
the various regulatory compliance HIPAA
PCI and so forth and again I just want
to stress that this is upstream
kubernetes and a hundred percent
compatible which means that when you
build applications on gke those
applications can easily run on
kubernetes implementations outside
google cloud as well so with that said
I'll hand it over to Rohit to talk about
cisco container platform wait
google kubernetes engine is kind of the
great place for you to get a cloud
managed kubernetes environment but from
Cisco's perspective and overall as the
partnership with Google what we have
been hearing from customers is they will
also want to start on the on-prem side
right as described in the third use case
where you want to maybe start in the
public cloud but also one are deployed
on Prem as you move into production or
you have multiple edge locations on
which you want to deploy your kubernetes
apps right so so we wanted to
essentially make sure that we give you a
certified kubernetes platform available
on the on Prem that integrates with the
infrastructure that you have on the on
Prem side and we talked about the
infrastructure because our customers as
our IT administrators the CIOs they have
invested in this in their infrastructure
over multiple years right and as the
transition to the cloud happens they
want to make sure that that investment
continues to pay off as the transition
to the cloud is happening so enabling
giving you a production ready turnkey
container platform on the on-premises
side helps to actually get benefit out
of your infrastructure investments as
well and as we go through the
presentation you will see how this
integrates with Cisco's infrastructure
specifically so as you can see on the
first first and foremost point this is a
fully hundred-percent upstream
kubernetes
in fact this is certified platform we
ran a bunch of CN CF test to make sure
it's compatible it is hybrid cloud
optimized from a Google perspective so
over the last year as we announced the
partnership back in October
Cisco's kubernetes engineering team has
been working very closely with Google
kubernetes engine team to ensure some of
the conflicts and other things that are
needed on a consistent environment of
the on-prem side we support that as part
of the deployment so things like
operating system where we start with
Ubuntu both in a very similar way in
both these environments against one of
the things that was mentioned in earlier
today in the keynote by Al and Kip
Compton was around how cisco container
platform is the first and only gke
certified platform and consistent with
GK running on the on-prem side third
from an integration perspective we
extend not just beyond networking and
storage but also from a cloud management
analytics perspective we have all of
these Cisco products that integrate to
give you
comprehensive multi-cloud capability
around the kubernetes environment that's
running on the on-prem side and then
finally from a flexible deployment
perspective we understand on the on prem
you have investments into virtual
machines where you are deploying your
existing workloads either on virtual
machines or bare metal servers so we are
giving you the flexibility to first spin
up these kubernetes clusters within
virtual machines but in the future will
also support bare metal infrastructure
where we'll give you all the automation
that's needed under the hood to bring up
a full infrastructure that is ready for
deploying all of these kubernetes bits
on on top of that in addition to this
again Cisco's networking infrastructure
from an ACR from an Sdn perspective we
integrate with that as well and we'll
get into those details just in a minute
so the first integration that I want to
talk about from an infrastructure
perspective is with our hyper flex
platforms our hyper flex platform is
essentially a hyper-converged
infrastructure that combines compute and
storage within an on-prem environment
and again this is already providing you
with the built-in Aya's platform so for
our virtual machines you are getting the
data management capabilities in terms of
replication as well as h.a on the
on-prem side but with the kubernetes and
the cisco container platform integration
we wanted to extend that support to pods
and kubernetes environment as well and
so the way we have done that is we have
developed a flex volume driver that
essentially gives you the persistent
volume support for pods or containers
that are running within a within a
kubernetes environment and the good part
is that this is as a turnkey
configuration as an administrator on the
on-prem side deploys the kubernetes
cluster they can pick and choose the
storage driver that they want to enable
for the persistent volume so in case if
pods move from one node to the other or
your virtual machines move from one node
to the other you're persistent volume
continues to be there because we chunk
the data as we write them into the disk
using the software that is running from
a storage perspective to chunk across
the multiple nodes as well as create the
replication in case of node failures so
all of those data management
capabilities that you have with virtual
machines on hyperflex
you get with containers that are running
within kubernetes as part of the cisco
container platform from a networking
perspective Cisco's application centric
interest
sure a CI that's our Sdn controller and
it essentially provides you with
connection network connection as part of
the Sdn fabric as well policy
implementation using our application
policy infrastructure controller called
APEC and what we have done here is we
have created a kubernetes CNI driver or
container networking interface driver
that essentially gives you both
kubernetes network connectivity as well
as kubernetes network policy
implementation within the ACI fabric so
imagine having an on-prem environment
with the ACI is rayon fabric where you
have bare metal infrastructure of
virtual machines as well as now
containers running with Cisco container
platform you can essentially have the
same fabric within your on-prem
environment to give connectivity and
apply policies in a very consistent way
and we scale in a way so that the fabric
is actually taking care of all the
network connectivity as well as
implementing policy rather than doing
everything on the host and overloading
your hosts with those constructs the
third integration piece that we have
done as part of the partnership and
integration is from a multi cloud
application management perspective
Cisco Cloud Center essentially supported
deployment of virtual machines and and
also talking to other cloud services and
defining a governance policy in terms of
what administrator's and what developers
can access to and what ports for example
can be opened up
but we've also added the support for
kubernetes so essentially you can deploy
define a Hamel definition or give a DML
definition in Cloud Center and point to
a kubernetes api whether that's running
on top of ccp or running within gke and
have a very consistent experience in
terms of deploying this across the
multiple cloud environments again with
the Cloud Center UI you also get the
capabilities to embed some of the agents
such as AB dynamics agent which we
recently announced kubernetes support as
well and so it gives you a turnkey
experience of not just deploying the
application but also embedding agents
from an application monitoring and
visibility perspective as well now keep
in mind all of these three integrations
I have talked about from a use case
three perspective which is we are giving
you a very consistent environment across
Jiki as well as on Prem and we've talked
about the hyper flex integration which
gives us storage we've talked about the
ACR integration which gives us the
networking and cloud Center which gives
us the application deployment construct
the last piece that I want to talk about
this use case and then dive into the
demo is hto and I'm pretty sure you've
heard about history all over it this
week and so HD was again like an open
source project like Allan mentioned that
was open source by Google IBM and left
about a year or so back and Cisco's got
involved into this open source project
as well and you'll see in the demo how
we're leveraging in use case 3 HD how it
plays a complete role in defining your
CI CD platform and deployments for
canary nab and testing so a very quick
high-level overview of HDO first
informants that gives you a service
discovery and not just for containers
but also for other workloads essentially
by running that sidecar proxy called
envoy which is what h2 is supporting you
can help to dynamically discover your
services across a multi cloud or a
hybrid environment then in terms of
having that sidecar proxy you can now
offload a lot of the lot of the
functionality there is very common to
your applications into the into your
sidecar proxy and this could be things
like circuit braking Frehley recovery
load balancing so things that have been
traditionally done specifically in the
application or by appliances in a
central location now you can have a
distributed model of implementing all of
these logic within that sidecar proxy
but hto gives you that control plane to
define how those things should behave
now since that sidecar proxies in the
path of deployment or your traffic you
can now also get all the telemetry and
observability between your services so
that gives you information about what is
the communication graph between
different services what is the latency
so you can go get all of those in terms
of a GK and a Cisco container platform
deployment that how are these micro
services or container workloads
communicating and what is the latency
between them and of course security is a
very important aspect because as we see
workloads moving out of the antrum
environment outside the firewall into
the public cloud you want to make sure
that is in there security not just at
the infrastructure level but also from a
networking perspective so you can create
VPN tunnels but at the HTTP level you
need things like MPLS or mutual security
TLS security that ensures that only the
right services are talking to the other
services that are deployed outside your
environment so if steel with its sidecar
proxy model gives you all of those
capabilities
in a hybrid environment and as part of
our use case 3 we provide that this is a
very quick high-level architecture
diagram of of how s2 is deployed you can
see the control plane has three
components it has the HT of pilot which
is responsible for essentially pushing
down and doing the service discovery and
pushing down the routing rules mixer is
essentially getting all the ingesting
all the data from the sidecar to give
you the observability and the and the
service graph and how communications are
happening and the code enforcement
between the different services and
finally Citadel which is these
essentially the service that's providing
MPLS between the various services that
are running as part of your server as
part of your service mesh so all of
these components talk to essentially
envoy which is deployed within each of
your application or micro service and
envoy exposes api's through which hto
communicates and enforces the policies
and that's what we will see in the demo
so specifically for for the hybrid use
case 3 one of the features that we have
actually pushed into the community and
it's going to be available as part of HT
of 1.0 is the multi cluster support and
my demo is all around this so it's very
important to understand what the multi
cluster support is here so what multi
cluster support does is you can have a
one single each to your control plane so
you're having essentially a single
instance of pilot mixture and Citadel
and that is essentially pushing down
policies into multiple envoys or
services that are running in your hybrid
environment now you may have seen things
like traffic director announcement
earlier from Google which is a managed
service with with this kind of a model
you can deploy an HT of control plane
either on google kubernetes engine or
you could deploy it on Prem right so it
gives you the flexibility to maintain
and manage your kubernetes control plane
as well as the issue of control plane
within your own environment and so
that's a key piece right so let's look
at the demo topology that we're going to
show this is the book info app again
available on the hto side we've got our
micro services deployment we've made up
of four different micro services our
product page which is the main entry
page and it talks to the reviews app it
talks to details and review
talks to ratings right so reviews is
essentially getting getting ratings
information from the rating service now
one thing to note here is I've got three
versions of reviews right so reviews one
gives me no stars reviews one gives me
black stars and reviews 3 gives me red
stars right so in our demo what we'd be
doing essentially is we'll start with
reviews v1 and v2 deployed on gke and
then we'll spin up reviews v3 on the
on-prem side as a new service and see
how traffic is getting load-balanced
right so this is our deployment
architecture from the gk side we'll have
all the services except reviews v3
running again this could also be a
completely flipped deployment where you
could have all of these things running
on Cisco container platform as well but
for this demo we'll have everything
running except for reviews v3 on google
kubernetes engine and then we'll spin up
reviews v3 on CCP or Cisco container
platform based kubernetes one important
thing to note here is the part I P
addresses are completely different
ranges so how do you actually ensure
that you are discovering these services
that are in completely different subnets
across these two environments so that's
where some of the magic that we have
done in terms of enabling for example
the cloud services router 1000v on
google cloud that helps you to create
that VPN tunnel so there is already a
VPN tunnel setup there is already
stealthWatch cloud which is monitoring
this disconnection from a security
perspective and we'll talk about the
details about that integration later as
well but that's all setup as part of
this tunnel between these two
environments so as we see into the demo
we'll see essentially all of these
services that are running we'll have a
sidecar proxy within it and that
essentially helps to discover their
services across the multiple across the
G key and the on-prem environment so
enough of this let's switch in to the
terminal here and actually see this in
action all right so this is my jump host
and this is running essentially a
virtual machine that is running on
Google Cloud and and it has a within as
part of that VPC deployment I have got a
VPN tunnel back to my own Prem
environment where I have got Cisco
container platform based kubernetes
deployment so here let's first do a get
into the gke deployment I will do cube
little context config get context and
you can see this is essentially my GK
based cluster we can go back here into
my browser and and see this is the
cluster that I'm essentially showing
Cisco live it is running in west 10.40
is the pot IP range has had shown in the
picture in this let's see what are the
different pods that are running right so
I'm gonna just do get pods this
essentially should return me from my app
perspective in the default namespace all
the services that I had shown except for
reviews v3 right so everything is
running on top of my google kubernetes
engine deployment let's look at the
services that are running here right so
essentially it will give me again in the
default namespace against those pods the
right services that are running right
now let's look at actually the services
in my HDS system namespace right so like
like I'd mentioned you have a complete
control plane of hto that is running and
in this case it's all deployed in google
kubernetes engine so I've got all of
these services that you see here that
are running on on the google kubernetes
engine one thing to note here is the
ingress gateway service this is my entry
point into my service mash and it has a
load balancer type you may be familiar
this from a kubernetes implementation
point of view and it has got an external
IP assigned to it and so I am going to
essentially be accessing my application
using this external IP right so this is
my entry point that takes the traffic
and then goes through the sidecar proxy
to all the services that are running
within the service mesh so just to
validate this let's remember this IP it
is 215 go back to our application and
see the front end page and you can see
here it's two one five I don't know that
if you can see that but trust me it's
two one five and we'll just refresh this
and and and as I'm doing refresh you can
see I am seeing no stars and black stars
so essentially that is reviews v1 and v2
getting lowest load-balanced as I'm
sending requests to my product page
across into the service mesh so let's go
back here into my terminal and what we
will do is we will go to the
on Prem side right so I just switched
contacts here I'm going to issue the
same command here and and I can show you
this is now a different context which is
based basically running a cisco contain
a platform provisioned kubernetes
cluster on top of my hyper flex cisco
hyper flex infrastructure with a CI
right so those are the storage drivers
and the networking plug-in that had been
enabled
what I'm gonna do here an issue same
similar commands here so I'm going to
first do get pods right and here
what we should see essentially is a
bunch of Cisco container platform
add-ons that we are enabling on the on
Prem side but no reviews v3 right so
that is the part that I'm going to spin
up a reviews v3 app here and see how
that how that works so let's look at the
reviews with free apps oh this is my
reviews v3 app ratings I have only got a
service definition because my reviews
talks to ratings but I don't have any
pods going to be running on Prem but
I've got a reviews definition and I've
got a deployment that says reviews v3
and as part of that I'm also giving a
sidecar proxy that I'm injecting which
is envoy as part of the deployment right
so let's go ahead and do a cube kernel
create - F Remora again because of the
CRTs that are supported within
kubernetes which has custom resource
definitions the definition of my remote
app which I just showed you with the
extensions of enabling on envoy or a
sidecar proxy in my app kubernetes with
the CRD support can understand it so
we'll go ahead and deploy this it just
got deployed we'll give it a few couple
of seconds for it to come up as it comes
up what is happening in the background
is essentially this service what the
sidecar proxy is getting registered with
my hto control plane that is running on
google kubernetes engine and as that
gets registered I now the control plane
essentially gets to know that if there
is a request that gives going to reviews
I can send it across to a new version
that has just come up so let's go back
to our app here and I'm gonna start
refreshing here again and what are you
seeing are red stars come up and and
essentially this this tells me that with
black stars that I am now starting to
load balance across multiple versions of
my reviews app that was running across
on Prem as well as GK environment right
so again you can see I'm continuously
just refreshing
and I'm seeing black stars and red stars
and there should be no stars as well
there you go
so in a random load-balancing fashion
this is happening traditionally or
previously if you had to do this in your
environment across G across a public
cloud and an on-prem environment you
would have probably a you know a load
balancer and in that load balancer you
would have a whip and that whips for
somehow needs to get configured with a
new back end of your service version
that comes up and there would have been
new manual configuration that you would
have to push in into the load balancer
do all of that but as you could see in
this demo as your developers spun up a
new version of an application your
operations team with this hto control
plane can now actually observe that a
new version has come up and assigned
rules in order to send the traffic to
these new versions in a very dynamic and
a very consistent way right so that's
one aspect of the demo now let's say
your operations or your developer says
reviews 3 is actually the best version
that I have seen so far and I want all
of my client traffic that's coming from
anywhere in the world to be now sent to
reviews v3 right so how do I actually
apply this policy into my service mesh
without disrupting the traffic to all
other versions and maybe without even
taking down my reviews v1 and v2 so for
that what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna
switch back into my gke environment
because that's where my steal control
plane is running and I'm going to look
at to a definition here of a policy
which is a virtual service constructor
in hto and this essentially is a policy
definition that says that if any traffic
to a destination called reviews I need
to send it to v3 right so if she
understands this it can push down into
the envoy sidecar proxy that's running
in my service mesh across these two
environments and then hopefully as we
try to again refresh our product page
entry it will send all the traffic to
reviews v3 so let's go ahead and do that
again with a cute cuddly create command
here and create that policy so it just
created that virtual service policy and
it's implementing that or into all the
Envoy sidecars that are running within
my deployment and I'm going to start
refreshing here again and what you see
here now as i refresh this only red
stars are getting shown
I'm not seeing any black stars I'm not
seeing any no stars which essentially is
telling me that that policy just got
applied into my service mash and my
developer gave thumbs up to this version
and my operator is now able to monitor
how my service is getting communicated
between the different micro services
additionally you can see here you know a
full graph of all the communication that
is happening within my service
deployment right so envoy from an
observability point of view gives you
this right out of the box that these are
the different services that are part of
the service mesh and the number of
connections and requests that are going
between these services now let's say
that you actually wanted to go back and
and do again the random load balancing
because you started to see some service
degradation right in that case you would
essentially want to go back here and
just delete this policy and hopefully
now everything should come back to what
it was before which is to load balance
across all the three versions of reviews
right so we if we go back here and start
refreshing or app here and you can see
Black Stars start to pop up red stars no
stars so I'm able to rollback my policy
definitions based on how my services are
are essentially performing into my
deployment and make those decisions
quickly and implement them very quickly
in a very consistent environment across
a hybrid environment because typically
you would do these things in a cloud
environment using things like security
groups or firewalls within those
environments and in the on-prem side you
would have again similar devices but
what the hto and service mesh model you
essentially have a layer between your LT
l 4 and l 7 to apply these policies once
and apply them very consistently across
these multiple environments so let's
switch back here to our slides that was
essentially the demo so like I mentioned
in this setup there was networking also
going on in the backend from an l3 l4
perspective as well as security and that
is essentially cutting across all of our
three use cases that we have so first
and foremost was the stealthWatch cloud
integration with Google Cloud or Google
V PC specifically here what we have
essentially our stealth Wars cloud is
essentially a SAS product from Cisco
that enables you to monitor that network
connections going into your VP series
sources in a cloud environment on also
your own primary resources here we have
integrated specifically with VPC flow
logs in google cloud so you can ingest
all the VPC flow logs on the google
cloud into the selvedge cloud service to
give you visibility things like what are
the number of network connections going
into your kubernetes pods or to your
virtual machines similarly are the on
the on-prem environment in cisco
container platform we enable the
deployment of stealthWatch sensors which
essentially puts all the net flow data
into the SAS service that's provided by
self watch cloud this service again was
available as has been g8 in March
earlier this year and is essentially
part of the solution the second
integration that was also in the demo
running in the background was cloud
services router 1000v cisco cloud
services router 1000v on google cloud
our csr 1000v has been very popular in
other clouds and based on a lot of a
customer request and as part of this
partnership we wanted to give a very
similar iOS on Prem kind of experience
on Google cloud for our customers and
that is what CSR 1000 B provides that
give you extended capabilities not just
from an IPSec perspective but also like
dmvpn and ackles that you can apply
across multiple on-premise data centers
or campus and branches using the CSR
running on Google cloud again this will
be part of the solution and enables you
to give that part to pod connectivity in
case if they're running in different
subnets so let's bring all of this
together right so we've talked a lot
about three different use cases
different components so how does this
all of this come together so as you can
see on the on Prem site starting with
the infrastructure you have got hyper
flex we've got a CI from Cisco we have
got the Cisco container platform that
integrates with these we've got Service
Catalog that enables you to consume ok
open service broker all the Google cloud
services we've got a shield that is
running on Prem or in Google Cloud to
give you the service mesh layer and then
Appaji gives you on Prem that capability
to expose your traditional systems for
things that are running in Google
kubernetes engine and then finally Cloud
Center get that gives you the capability
to deploy these things across multiple
environments so this is our overall
architecture that brings everything
together
this is going to be as Alan mentioned a
Cisco validated
design so all the components that you
see in this picture they will be
available to you as single products but
with the joint partnership we are going
to be giving you validated designs that
ensures that these are working together
they give you the benefit of making them
work together as well as supporter
jointly by Cisco and Google so things
like when you need kubernetes support
when you need a steer support they will
be jointly supported by Cisco and Google
as part of this entire partnership and
solution now one of the things that we
have done here that that that over the
last few months as we have announced
this partnership are the various
milestones that you see in this picture
right so cisco joined the h2 community
back in july 2017 the feature that i
just showed you was pushed through cisco
working very closely with google
engineers we announced the hybrid cloud
partnership back in october at the
partnership minutes the Cisco's partner
summit in November we announced the
multi cloud portfolio in which hybrid
cloud is also part of it January in
Cisco by Barcelona we announced the
Cisco container platform and then
stealthWatch cloud and the cloud center
Abdi kubernetes support followed on at
this conference we announced another
thing was the Cisco and Google Cloud
definite challenge so this is the
challenge that essentially leverages a
lot of the technology components that we
that I have talked about so far so
things like Cisco container platform
Google kubernetes engine if steel and
there are multiple prizes that are to be
awarded as part of this challenge we
have opened up registration for it
here's the URL for it that you can check
it out
but the key thing to remember here is
that we see not only those three use
cases as the starting point but opening
up the technology components to our
customers to our developers and partners
to innovate around using these use case
so at the end closing this and we'll
open up for questions here is that we
want to essentially give you a platform
that is supported by Cisco that enables
you to move to the public cloud at your
own pace you can innovate and move to
modernization as well as you leverage
open source components in your
environment that is supported jointly by
Cisco and Google
[Music]